what up space fam goes in here from
anime opera and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest crazy chapter of the
one piece manga and i gotta say
this one was great so make sure to stay
tuned for that if you do enjoy seeing
these one-piece chapter reviews and want
to keep them coming then channel the
pirate king within
and smash that like button until it's
blue if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is crucial hit that
notification bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
reviews and while you wait for the next
chapter to drop which
will be next week by the way feel free
to check out our growing one piece
playlist
where we got videos about all the yonko
warlord supernova and much
more link to that is in the description
now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all you
can't help but enjoy
this week's cover art which includes
karakuri sharing milk and donuts with
hungry puppies and kittens however if
for some reason there is someone out
there
who doesn't like katakuri sweets puppies
and kittens all of them then you
obviously
won't enjoy it and also i don't
understand how you can exist
but moving on we continue where we left
off with the helpless sanji who can't
fight girls
versus black maria a very strong brutal
girl
remember black maria wants sanji to call
out for nico robin so they can capture
her for kaido
obviously we would assume that sanji
would play the white knight
and would never agree to lure nico robin
into a trap by calling out to her black
maria set it up so that at the entrance
robin would be ensnared by her web and
then they'd shoot her up with
tranquilizers black maria is definitely
a very dangerous woman and she puts
brass knuckles on
and commences to beat up sanji who is
tied up to her webs
and continues to bounce back again and
again so he can get brutally beaten
time after time he's a fancy punching
bag for this giant sexy spider lady at
this point you wouldn't think that such
a brutal moment
would end up being so hilarious but it
does this
is one piece humor at its best for me
initially they
like most of us assume that sanji is
this brave chivalrous man who would
rather
die than risk putting his friend in
harm's way so as maria is whooping his
butt
her underlings are feeling great pity
for sanji they can't hold back the tears
they make all these assumptions like
he'd rather die
than ask for help if it means
endangering his friends and another
mentions that she might have fallen in
love with him if they weren't on
different sides
clearly this one hasn't read romeo and
juliet finally sanji yells out stop
and says how am i supposed to get a word
in if you keep hitting me
now people assume he'll do a cool thing
like tell her to screw off
remain defiant and say he'll never give
in
but no sanji exactly as instructed
shouts for robin to save him and we get
a hilarious shocked reaction from
everyone
because he gave in so easily even black
maria is shocked he gives the location
says he's being held hostage and
apologizes he says if she doesn't come
he'll be killed sanji begs to be saved
he gets called pathetic by listeners
because remember this is getting
broadcasted everywhere
in the meantime we see some hype
matchups like marco and king
and jinbe and who's who i love how
jinbei looks completely chill and even
comments on robin in the middle of his
fight we get to see frankie versus
sasaki
and at this point sanji's manhood is
even questioned immediately nami
concludes
that he must be up against a woman
knowing that's the only thing that makes
sense
so tell me what you think of sanji's
decision to call robin i gotta admit
i thought this might be one of those
honorable scenes that we get often from
zorro where he's willing to take
unbearable punishment for his crew
but this isn't what happened sanji is
not zoro
and i actually like what happened here
but we need to keep going so i can fully
explain why
sanji asked to be taken down now that he
did what he was asked to do but surprise
surprise
maria is not too honest she plans to
keep him
as a pet and we see some men who say
they only love maria however
and this part i love sanji screams no
i love them all all the ladies of the
world
this part was so enjoyable and i love
how his love for all women
sort of keeps him from being whipped by
just one the cure for being a simp
funnily enough is to simp
indiscriminately over all women
black maria though doesn't like shared
attention or cheating so she decides to
beat sanji some more to discipline him
wow black maria is much more savage than
i thought she would be i have to admit
that
and then as sanji points out he can't
use armament hockey psychologically he
can't do anything that might hurt a girl
even if he's defending himself so we
can't really blame him for not being
able to fight girls because he simply
cannot
do it it's out of the question and then
we get such
a nice and satisfying slap from robin
delivered to black maria
robin sends her flying and reveals that
she can bloom
anywhere so the entrance trap was indeed
pointless
sanji cries when he sees robin and you
gotta give it to oda he gave robin
such an epic moment and entrance here
she tells black maria that seeing her
friends mistreated brings out the devil
in her in this way she plays on her
nickname devil child
in such a cool way and the serious look
in her eyes
it's just so hype in the meantime brooke
comes in and uses the underworld's chill
to cut sanji free and his entrance is
amazing too
saying pardon me but i already cut you
free brook
is super effective here and we're told
all of the spider webs are breaking
apart
because of brooks frost and then there's
the hilarious moment of seeing brook
seeing the underlings and screaming out
ah
monsters despite the fact that he's a
walking talking skeleton
man i love this skeleton so much sanji
goes rushing off to help kinemon and the
others knowing he can't help here
sanji runs from the scene as robin keeps
getting cooler and cooler asking black
maria
about her last words and everything she
also has a
heartwarming beautiful moment where she
smiles and says that sanji made her day
and thanks him for counting on her my
heart is
melting as i revisit this and like me
sanji has hearts in his eyes as he looks
at robin
and leaves and of course slips because
it's icy at the entrance thanks to
brooke
so now did sanji come off kind of lame
here compared to if he stoically took a
savage beating and refused to cooperate
with black maria i mean you could make
that
argument but i still enjoyed this moment
because it reminds us about what this
whole nakama stuff is about
although it's super super inconvenient
the truth is
sanji can't fight women he just can't do
it so it makes sense that he would ask
his crew for help to help him
where he can't help so that he can help
elsewhere
now i'll try not to say the word help
for a while but anyways that is the
ultimate good for the crew
at the same time he trusts in robin
remember in the last chapter he told
black maria not to underestimate nico
robin
he doesn't view her as someone who needs
protecting rather he views her as
someone he can rely on when necessary
and not just that robin is extremely
touched that sanji feels this way
she's had trouble finding a purpose to
exist in the past
and by showing her she's needed sanji is
actually doing her a big favor too
all around do i think that zoro would
have been cooler in this situation
yeah but sanji is also great and he
recognizes his shortcomings
and of course he would rely on his
nakama just as he'd want them to rely on
him
when they need to we don't rely on zorro
for directions
and we shouldn't rely on sanji for
fighting girls we just have to accept
that
we jump to momonosuke yamato and shinobu
their place is surrounded so what
is the only logical solution well of
course it is to keep momonosuke safe and
out of sight
bye wait for it having momonosuke high
under yamato's clothing
man this is one lucky shogun shinobu and
yamato break out and yamato decides to
knock the enemies out so they won't be
able to see
taking shinobu's worries about being
seen very literally
and very hilariously we see jack back in
the mix
and he says he will take care of the
samurai putting down the flying six
by saying that the flying six can't
handle the samurai
even if they are on death's door that's
actually a very interesting turn and it
seems like sanji and jack are going to
be meeting up soon which would be a
fight i enjoy seeing
maria accepts although she says she is
being severely
underestimated earlier on we had yamato
take off her clothes
and now we have maria doing it too man
you gotta love oda i have no idea
how they'll show this fight but she is
no longer wearing the upper part of her
kimono we see a crazy weapon in her hand
and the tattoo on her back reads dangers
of women
definitely fitting for black maria's
whole black widow angle
she's attractive enough to lure men in
and strong enough to kill them
or make them her slaves she tells robin
that she belongs to kaido
and robin looking beautiful says no
thanks i'd rather die
and of course brooke is blushing because
there is a naked attractive woman
right in front of him oh man the
combination of serious
fights and significant stakes with laugh
out loud humor
makes one piece so unique and amazing i
love this chapter
so much even if there wasn't some crazy
reveal or crazy fight but i guess it
depends on how you define a crazy reveal
but anyways that's a sign of a good
mangaka
that he can make quote unquote in
between chapters this good
i didn't even miss the rooftop fight
although now that i mention it i do
really want to know what's going on
up there hopefully oda will let us know
soon but i'm not complaining this was
great
and robin and brooke to me personally
were especially
exceptional as always let me know what
you thought of it and what you expect to
see happening next you guys know i loved
it
we didn't figure out who the mystery
figure was yet but we will soon enough
hopefully there's so much to look
forward to
if you do enjoy seeing these one piece
trapped reviews and want to keep them
coming then
channel the pyroking within and smash
that like button until it's blue
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future one piece videos
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop which will be next week by the
way
feel free to check out our growing one
piece playlist where we got videos
about the yonko warlords supernova and
much more link to that is in the
description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one-tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
in grotto the world acquire respect but
they have a liam thompson
al-jatal dr kortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku
spidey life tinel baked buddhist and
tungsten tarkis and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kozlowski
joe stanton barry gucci
jessica kayla fond rethuen de ora alicia
actor bonnie parks hinokami and water
the red-haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games ted note head deadly saint matthew
cruz and anthony schreiber thank you all
so much
if you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing epic
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime
life waifus and of course dank memes
so check out patreon.com anime upload
link to that is in the description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue drawing button next to the
subscribe button
that you've hopefully already clicked so
yeah you can support more content that
way if you prefer
whichever way you support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you